um
cute afternoon everybody uh thank you
all for joining this uh panel on how to
join the quantum workforce my name is
florian carl i'm the manager of the yale
quantum institute
and i'll be one of the moderators for
this panel
so we are delighted to continue this
series of talks and and panel and
that are organized jointly with the
engineering workforce development of the
center for quantum network in arizona uh
and the yellow quantum institute
this is the third panel in our series uh
on focusing to prepare today on how to
get a job or like how to put all your
chances on your site to get a job
in academia and to have to become an
assistant professor or have any faculty
position
so we wanted to uh to offer this series
of professional development uh panels
because building quantum technology
really requires a lot of people from
different backgrounds we need physicists
electrical engineer computer scientists
software engineer chemists and it can be
a little bit overwhelming uh to consider
all the options and all the carrier you
can have in the field of quantum science
information
um so today we'll hear from uh postdocs
and recent faculty members
that
that will talk about the experience on
uh what it's like to work in the villa
of quantum and get advice on navigating
the various uh pathways to do uh an
academic career
um so the my colleague uh russell
valiant who is the assistant director of
the center for quantum network uh will
serve as a moderator and i will let him
introduce himself
and talk a little bit more about
the
center yep so um as florian said i'm
russell paulier i'm the assistant
director for engineering workforce
development for the center of quantum
networks
um
who is a new center and just kind of
getting started and we'll be laying the
foundations for the quantum networks and
the technologies as well as looking at
the societal impacts and probably the
reason we want to do this panel is to
help develop the engineering workforce
development and give you all a little
bit of information uh about how you can
join the quantum workforce
thank you and then you have on my uh on
my webcam some information about the
center
so you can also subscribe to their
youtube channel to have all the
information about this center
um so uh before we introduce uh the the
rest of the panelists um i want to
walk you through a little bit of
housekeeping so we are recording this
advance and so it'll be available in
replay if you want and then you can use
the chat the q a feature in zoom so at
the bottom you should have two speech
bubble you can just answer uh ask all
your questions and then we'll try to go
through uh all of them so you can have
uh really um like a better understanding
on what it will take to uh get one of
these positions
okay so let's start by uh introducing
our panelists um so please you can feel
free to turn on your webcams
and uh we'll start with uh lynn run fan
from the university of arizona
uh hi everyone so i'm nihan
uh so right now i'm an assistant
professor at college of optical sciences
at university of arizona
so i graduated from yale university in
electrical engineering in 2017
so it's good to see some familiar names
from yqi so i spent six years on hill
house avenue
yeah so right now i'm part of the
uh the sequence the center for quantum
network sense center
so right now my group is working on
quantum integrated photonics and
especially
related to quantum sensing and
continuous variable quantum uh quantum
information
and right now in my group i have
two postdocs and six graduate students
so
yeah so and i actually joined the
faculty of university of arizona in
2018 yeah so it's i just passed my three
year major review actually
so if you have any questions feel free
to ask me
thank you
and the the 3m review is always a little
bit stressful i guess
good luck with that
yeah
uh surely do you want to go
introduce yourself yeah hi my name is
shruti um and i'm a assistant in the
applied physics department at yale i
just started last year in july
um so i'm so quite new
um and you know i'm a theorist i work in
quantum information theory my i've
always been interested in quantum
mechanics like you know when i was um in
high school i i heard about the fact
that
you know
particles can interfere like waves and
so on and so that just blew my mind
so you wanted to study quantum mechanics
further and then when i came to grad
school
i was
very intrigued by the fact that you
could
compute using the principles of quantum
mechanics like you can imagine building
an operating system
based on quantum mechanics so that was
just completely bizarre and i just just
wanted to be a part of this
uh mysterious uh field
and so you know that's how my journey
started
um and now uh you know i just started my
group last year i have
two uh graduate students one post doc
and two new graduate students are coming
uh are joining us this fall
and i also have an undergrad uh working
with the team so that's my story
perfect thank you very much
uh and then so this is uh so lin ryan
and trudy can uh tell us about their
experience as our recent faculty member
and then we also wanted to include uh
anderson brito who is the co-chair of
the yelp positional association and so
um you can introduce yourself
yeah so thank you very much for having
me here today it's really a pleasure
to be here sharing a little bit of my
experience as as a postdoc
and i am not a a a quantum scientist
let's say i am a biologist with a
master's in
virology and a phd in in computational
biology so i have this
very
interdisciplinary
sort of back background
and as
was just said by
by by by
sorry by by florian i am here basically
representing the yale post doctor
association as one of the co-chairs
currently
and i got invited by florian which was
one of our of of of our
co-chairs in the past and a founder
member of these of these yale
association
and it's really nice to be here today to
share a little bit of my of my
experience as a postdoc at ea
thank you
thank you very much uh and yes do you
never underestimate the power of
networking uh because even if we uh if
we haven't met you i will reach out to
you and we can we can do great great
things
uh so okay let's uh kickstart this um
this meeting uh and and we're gonna ask
we're gonna answer some of the question
and so i think the first one that comes
in mind when we think about faculty
member is uh the stress as postdocs and
as senior grad students of
how can i find a faculty position and
like what are the steps and so can we uh
can we have either uh shady or lynn ryan
uh go over the the the process of like
what are all the steps that you took to
uh to get this position and you can you
can uh
answer that from any angles that uh you
thought would be helpful
maybe we can start by uh shreddi
okay
uh yeah so for me the process was um you
know you basically hear about
you have to keep an eye
so for me i kind of was looking where i
wanted to be and so i kept an eye about
on the hiring
market in in those particular
universities
and also like my colleagues knew that i
was looking so they would forward me you
know any announcements uh
made about hiring at their university so
you basically
you can be proactive and looking for
open positions at places or you know you
can obviously take help from your
colleagues about this
um and once you you know
usually the process starts around
september october you know you kind of
know where you want to go by september
and then
the deadlines for applications are
around october december uh sometimes
late december
so you basically prepare your
application process which is like your
cv you have to write a research
statement basically you want to in your
research statement you want to convey
um
the things that you want to do in the
next five years
or so in your in your research group
and then you know you have to write a
teaching statement sometimes you have to
write diversity statements
um and then you know there's blank you
just have to wait after after all the
applications are sent in you just
have to wait and have faith that
somebody's actually found your
application and is reading it and
eventually you'll um you know hear from
places they'll
sometimes
they call you to have like a phone
interview
uh which which is usually like maybe 30
minutes sometimes it's even shorter
and then when if you
you know go through that then they'll
call for in-person
interviews
so i had
in some cases both phone interviews and
in-person interviews
and then again there's a blank
you wait for a long time to hear back
and sometimes you have to you know bring
them and be like hey what's where is the
application process at
um
so yeah that was my
overall uh experience maybe i missed
something ellen do you want to add in
um yeah so i think you'll probably cover
all the aspects of the factory search
but my experience is a little bit
different i mean at florin and anderson
uh and also shooti you imagine that
networking is actually quite important
so the reason
why i got this position is actually
uh i was very lucky that when i was a
postdoc so i was not prepared for
effective position at that time and i
was approached by some colleagues that i
knew when i was a graduate student and
also i got some information from my
advisors and so okay there's the effect
position i think that can fit you well
and why don't you apply it and then
apply it and that's why i got it
and the preparation is quite similar
right so we need to prepare the cd write
the research statement
and uh the teaching statement diversity
statement and all kind stuff
and also normally we need to give like
two talks one is the research talk about
your uh about your work one is like a
name
talk
to present your uh research ideas for
your future group so
and i think both of them are very
important
and the research talk
presents your capability and the top
talk
will show how you uh how you will lead
the group as indeed as an independent
researcher i think that's also very
important
especially nowadays i believe most
universities when they post the
effective position they
kind of have a uh idea what kind of
background what kind of person they are
looking for so if you are uh
uh
so
if
your future plan matches their
idea i think that will be very helpful
yeah
um
how many uh how many applications can
you give you guys a ratio of like how
many applications did you send how many
responses you get because we always hear
like the there's very there's more
production of phds than a position
available which i think in quantum is
we're in a weird bubble these days um i
calculated that last year there was 161
faculty position open uh in the us uh in
quantum uh so it's quite a lot uh for
the field it's a very hot topic uh but
like can you give us a ratio of how many
uh interview or like how many positions
uh did you interview for and uh and like
how many offered like you can also keep
that confidential just give us like a
bulk order if you don't want to like
disclose any of the other things
so for me sorry no go ahead
no surely i think you can go ahead
because my case is not common
right so for me i actually uh went
through the job market twice
uh one was
2018 2019 uh round and then the other
one was 20 19 20 20 rounds
so in the first round when i applied um
there were much fewer
uh quantum jobs open
um
i i think there was
i can't remember exactly how many but i
i think it was like around five-ish or
more universities that i applied to but
none of them actually said quantum
information in it a lot of times they
you know
um
send out you know a more general call so
unless you have an inside idea about
what they're exactly looking for you
know you don't know and i just wanted to
get an experience like you know get out
the bad interviews before uh and so i
was like yeah i'm gonna apply and see
how it goes so that in that round um
uh you know i got one interview and
that's i didn't get a job
uh fortunately i didn't get a job so
that
i could get a job at yale uh so i'm very
happy about that um so in the second
round the second year the 2019-2020 year
was like amazing year for quantum
as uh florian said there were so many
job openings uh in our fields um and
again i think i applied to about
eight nine universities or so uh
i think i pretty much got calls
from everybody except maybe two places
um
and so it was a very stressful time
because you know these these job
interviews
take two days in like at least two or
three days and then you're
you know you're basically on from eight
in the morning to eight in the night
um
and yeah so
yeah then i then you
like i said i didn't get called i think
from two places maybe three uh i got
in-person interviews
um and then i got offers from a few
places uh again very lucky because i
know that during that time many people's
um
offers were drawn due to the pandemic
fortunately that did not happen for me
um
and yeah that's when i landed at you
yeah my experience is not i mean yeah
because i was approached by uh some
colleagues so at i think in 2018 i just
applied here the only place i applied is
universal arizona and uh
so and luckily i got this position and
after interview i found okay this is a
good place and uh
i like the environment and the research
and it has all the capabilities that i
need for my experiments so
i just decided to join but from my uh
experience talking to other colleagues
so
um
yeah the ritual is not good i mean but
it's not bad so
as i think probably on average
one-third will be get a call and
normally
uh so people uh university will invite
like around three to eight people from
for on-site interview and they will have
a waiting list and if you are in the top
three then i think you have a pretty
hair chance because i mean normally like
shruti you will get offers from several
places and you can only accept one so
then for other places if you will
decline that offer the
second person on that list will uh will
be offered the position right so
so that's why
uh shooting mention a lot of plenty
times right so there will be a lot of
waiting times during the faculty
search yeah
we have a question in the in the q a um
how long did it take for you to prepare
your research and teaching statements so
in preparing the for the interviews uh
was any aspect of it particularly
challenging
so um
so actually it's not long normally just
one page or two pages so
not
long i mean but it's uh it takes a lot
of time to prepare that two-page
research statement i believe and
yeah i think the key is that you need to
kind of make a connection to our
previous background but you need to find
a new angle to distinguish yourself i
think that's probably the most
challenging part for myself
i can i was actually trying to open up
my research statement to see how long it
was but i was not fast enough but
for me it was much longer um so i think
the question is not about the the size
of the bishop statement it was more like
but yeah i mean it depends on also how
long you have to make it right but like
i started uh preparing my research
statement
like over the summer uh because it
there's a lot of thought that goes in
there uh you have to show them that you
are capable of conducting new research
and support you know ex-graduate
students over the next five years so you
have to
show them that you know you're capable
of building this whole research program
you're not a postdoc anymore you're not
just going to work on this one little
project you're gonna
like lead a huge group um so it takes a
lot of time and effort and you know
uh the teaching statement i spend much
less time compared to the research
statement it is less important than well
it's not less important it's equally
important but it's you know it's usually
only two pages so it goes a bit faster
than the then the research statement and
then you you know you have to write it
early on so that you have time to send
it to your colleagues your advisor to
get feedback from them
um and you know uh yeah so basically i
would say
by september and at least it should be
ready um and you should already be
getting feedback from your colleagues
thank you both
um in you were talking about the fact
that your case was a little bit special
because you sort of got uh picked up by
like one of your colleagues and so i
would like to talk about the importance
of networking and connection in this
field uh can you uh how did you build
your how did you start building your
network um and then was it like your
direct colleague or was it like a more
extended network of of researcher and
fellow colleague
uh so it's more extended networks so
because
yeah apart from information especially
within the u.s so it's uh
even though it's vastly growing but it's
not a huge community so i guess most
people know each other in the field and
many cases um maybe your advisor will
some collaborate uh projects with some
uh professors in other universities and
if the other university has a faculty
opening they will reach out to you to
your advisor and also to some institutes
like what uh yqi so that's how i know
this position yeah
and so the reason i was asking about
networking is because um we are in the
us
and i think in
many universities in the world they're
starting to build a postdoctoral
association that helps with the
networking uh and i would like to uh to
uh have a little bit more information
about physical association with uh
anderson can you talk a little bit about
ypa and your involvements with the
association
and yeah
i'll pull up the the website of
the ypa yeah sure so
this is this is a quite young
association it was founded around seven
years ago
but since then it's been growing quite a
lot and in my view it's it has been
transforming the experience of of
of postdocs and also associate research
scientists
at yale by
exactly favoring
networking community building
because these these are one of the the
the the main aims of the year
post-doctoral association
in the ypa we try always to create this
sense of community engagement and also
we we always try to allow
a positive experience at the at the
university
by
for example organizing events that are
focused on on professional development
likes like seminars and also and also
you know workshops but also social
events which due to the pandemic will
actually stop for a while but we we have
still been doing that via the internet
by using zoom for example
and as florian mentioned we should never
underestimate the power
of networking because we may need
someone from an unrelated field and that
person may eventually be your connection
to someone in
in your field by
many other means because the person is
of the same nationality of a researcher
in your field there are many ways
for you to get connected and indirectly
to someone
in your field by just meeting people
that are from other fields that are
let's say in the same uh
level of your career so i guess most of
the people here
they they
they are they are post docs wanting to
transition
into
a
a let's say academic career
and by being a member of an association
there are many benefits i have just
mentioned
the benefits
related to networking which is one of
those let's say
transferable
soft skills that we
learn
via
extra curricular activities because it's
quite common to see people focusing a
lot on research skills and they
sometimes forget to is to strengthen a
little bit
of other skills that they can also
develop like communication skills
networking leadership time management
project manage management
all of these soft skills they are
extremely uh necessary
for a successful a successful career and
by being a member of of by being a
member of an association you
gain some of of these
skills by taking part of trainings that
such association
may offer but if you also join as an
officer of that association
you would also have opportunities to
strengthen such skills by organizing
events
events yourself by basically being the
leader of a group that has a project
within the us the association that has
to be finished within a defined time so
all of these sort of
non-research activities they somehow
teach us is skills that are extremely
helpful as well in our academic career
thank you very much and and while you
talk i have the the website of the ypa
and uh on my screen so it's ypa.tl.edu
and
the people in the university of arizona
also have their own website it's a
similar association it's uh ua
postdocs.webley.com so you can you can
go and check what you uh
uh if you can make new connection and i
really agree that all the all the work
that you will do if you engage in the
leadership of this association is really
really helpful because you will start
building connection and also you will
talk to a leadership and it's easy to
talk to people on your uh on your level
on your peers
but it's also a different thing uh to
start having to ask things to uh
university leadership and i think it's a
good training also for the drop dogs
because that's that's what you're gonna
do you're gonna try to convince uh above
your uh above your grade and so that's i
think it's a it's a pretty important
thing
and um all the skills that you develop
um maybe we can go back to uh shorty and
enrants talking about like what kind of
um other skills do you need to have to
build a research group because i think
the more you goes in the more you go
into um faculty of your job your job is
not to do the research as much as you do
but like more managing students and
writing brands and you have a ton of uh
serving on panels at the universities uh
and other activities can you talk a
little bit more about this uh these
extra activities that um grad students
supposedly are not necessarily aware of
who want to start
yeah
yeah i can get started so
uh yeah you are right so it's very
different to be a phd student or even
postdoc
with uh being a faculty member so when i
was a phd student or postdoc we just
need to focus on one or two projects you
just need to think about how to do your
experiment better and how to
uh
yeah so how to finish the experiment but
as a
faculty member i think the biggest
change is that
we don't really have a lot of time
digging into the details of other
projects but on the other hand we still
need to provide the
big picture guide students especially
when we start a new group so you are the
most knowledgeable people in the group
but on the other hand you have the least
the time to
dig into the details of the experiment i
think that's the
biggest challenge i've i faced so
um yeah so
i think uh it's good uh it's better to
balance the time you work on proposals
and also i still reserve a quite amount
of time doing experiments with the
student at least for the first several
years
so therefore we can accelerate the
process
but i think from uh
it might be different from uh for
theoretical groups so i think shruti can
um say more about that but for
experiments groups i think that
i treat myself as a half post-op at
least for the first year so i still do a
lot of like
experiments
i went into i went into the clean room
with the students together just uh
helped them do the fabrication through
all the experiments but after
uh three years when the first student or
two students are well trained and they
are good enough that i can spend more
time on other stuff
yeah you know my sentiment is the same
thing i i always say that
having a research group is like having a
startup and so basically whatever skills
you need to have a startup is what you
need you need to
be able to write grants uh and bring in
money you have to support your students
you do get a startup package but you
know that's not going to last you
forever um and so
the advice i was given was like you know
save that money as much as possible and
just you know start writing grants uh
from day one which is which is what i
did
um
it's not only that you as as lynron also
said you have you know you you're not
gonna
you have to you know prepare for your
classes you have to prepare your new
courses that you're gonna teach you're
gonna write write grants so you don't
yourself have a lot of time for research
um so fortunately in my case um
uh right in the beginning i had a
student uh to join my group and she was
you know pretty much at a good place
but i started like a quite different
project with different set of skill sets
for her but she caught on really fast
and so you need to be able to identify
you know
fast learners i guess and uh take them
on and right like right now she is
so good that i don't basically she's
training the new students coming in uh
so so she is
really you know the
i would say i could not
have i could not take more students on
without her i would not have the time to
deal with everybody at that level
uh the other thing is you know again
like you know hiring post docs and stuff
you need to be able to judge them like
you know when they come get you know
when you're interviewing them and they
come give talks to you you need to be
able to write ask the right questions
and judge their capability
again hiring the right people is going
to change your life like i hired a
postdoc who's good i don't have to you
know like just
tell him like okay here we're thinking
about this
you know go figure it out and he figures
it out so
um right so after after a while you need
it to be a self-sustaining thing you
cannot be
you know person who's actually writing
codes or
you know figuring out the math and stuff
so these are the skill sets that you
don't necessarily have as a postdoc
but you know
you you need to develop
is there any is there any place that's
like how did you learn this skill like
is it on the job like first day you
you're they're just pushing the jeep and
it's like okay you used to be a postdoc
now you need to interview you need to
write grants and all these things is
there any resources somewhere that helps
you i mean i would say that as
especially for grants i mean like
judging somebody somebody's capabilities
like how do you teach that right um you
just like you know
for me it's like observe and people are
giving talks um and and hear what
you know your advisors are saying about
those speakers so you know like just
just you know catch on to things that
they're saying so that's how you learn
also ask
uh in my case as a postdoc i did not get
a lot of chance to be involved in grants
uh
i got a chance to involve in one grand
but not you know
mostly for the scientific part not so
much the writing but i would suggest
that if there's one thing i could go
back and redo again would be ask my
advisors can i be part of this grant so
i i learned the procedure and i you know
get um
some like training of how to how how
these things work how you should present
your work and so on so forth
and speaking of grants i know a lot of
universities are giving
classes and resources and there's
are you familiar with this uh anderson
do you want to talk about uh grant
writing that can be offered by the uh
the possible affairs
yeah so
one thing that we have been
that's working a lot to make sure that
we can offer
to our
members is exactly professional
development uh events especially
workshops we have been organizing
we have been organizing workshops about
branch about grant sorry grant writing
article writing like
scientific writing let's say
and these are resources that
we can get out of yale because yale has
many offices that organizes
uh
different different sorts of
of workshops they have they are experts
on those specific topics and they can
teach us but we have to somehow connect
with them
and make such requests
and this is something that we are quite
happy to to see that we that the ypa has
been this very important let's say
intermediate facilitating
that such
training can can
can
let's say be offered to
to our to our top to our members because
definitely having a method for writing
grants and papers
this makes a huge difference if you know
how to structure things first before
writing that
that can speed up the process and the
final piece would look much more much
more cohesive for example
and yeah these sort of trainings
we can get
out of uh let's say being member of of a
local association of of of post docs
and if such association does not exist
in
your location you could even create your
own start things from east from scratch
and this is this is what happened to me
uh when uh so i
did my pg in france moved to yale as a
postdoc and then there was nobody to
help and so a bunch of post-docs that we
met uh mostly european because of the
the logical uh the geographical
connection we have this mini network of
foreigners that uh uh met at the office
that visa office at hl uh got together
and starting to say like hey how can we
help each other because i think that's
also the the trick on everything like
you should network you should help
everybody but i think if you find
interest like if it's useful to you it's
going to be useful to others and so it's
something that you can do and we're
talking about tl and u of a
a lot because this is our affiliations
but this is uh valid for all the
university in uh in the us and also
in most of the world i think
the university is starting to see that
people need resources similar to that to
prep to prep them for the job market so
they they are offering workshop and and
now with the uh with the pandemic i
think everybody shifted to a virtual
world and i'm pretty sure even if your
university doesn't uh offer this kind of
thing you can find virtual workshops
that you can attend or like view
recordings online like similar to one of
these things so it's really something
that you should try to think about
because in an ideal world you are really
good at what you're doing in your
research but the the key where you're
going to be judged for the applications
and for these things is going to be
everything else can you be the extra
like the
are you the superstar in the field and i
think that's what people are looking in
universities
um and so yeah that was one thing and
also one thing that i want to add uh
we're talking about like how to get a
job but there's also an interesting
thing and i'm sorry i'm gonna bring the
mood a little bit down but not
everybody's cut up to be a faculty
member uh and i think it's very
important to to realize like do i want
to do that because it's the it's the
path that you want to do uh or is it
because your advisor told you like hey
this is what you do you do a phd you do
a postdoc and then you do a faculty and
so there's also something you need to to
think about is that
is that the kind of job that i want and
is it matching my skills and what i want
to do and there's a ton of new
different jobs in quantum uh we're gonna
cover in the fall uh the the startup
world and the industry role so there's
gonna be i think there's also more and
more option for a job in in the quantum
workforce and so if if you're scared
about writing grants or if you said
about other things that there's also
there's different possibilities um so
we'll work on these things
we have another question in the chat um
mostly for uh shirley because you went
to uh two different rounds of
application
they wanted to know if uh is it better
to
wait a turn like if you apply and then
get a position that you could do better
next time is it is it worth taking it or
would it would it look bad similar to
like burning bridges if you decide to
refuse the this and then try to try to
get a better option next year what's
your take on that
but i i think as as long as i don't know
you don't hit somebody over there you're
not gonna like burn any bridges
they're not um
like when you when you if you're called
for an interview and you're not the
first choice or you know not one of the
top three choices it doesn't mean that
you are
bad or you you know you don't have the
skills it's just that you you're not
right now fit for the
particular direction that the university
is looking at uh it so to me uh
it doesn't show anything negative
that being said i would say strike when
the iron is hot um
you know there are some key papers that
you're going to publish
in your career
when those hot papers come out
apply for a position you need to be
out there and and that's when you're
going to be more popular don't wait for
like you know two more years because
after two more years you may not have
that another hot paper again and then
you know your chances are going to be uh
lower
um you're talking about hot paper and
like how do you uh can can you both talk
about how can you strengthen your
application uh do you need to have
teaching experience do you need to have
grants like what are the what are the
things you can do as senior grad
students or as a postdoc to
like have a really strong case for the
university to hire you
um
yeah so i think uh of course first of
all we need to have a
good research background so that's the
foundation for everything i believe and
on top of that i think that if you have
some experience uh getting some
grants as uh phd students or postdocs i
think that will add points to it but i
believe uh in terms of
uh
in the community of quantum information
i think there are not many chances for
postdoc to write brands ib because i
know that for biology and
medical schools postdocs can apply for
grants but that's not very common in
quantum information area
yeah but on the other hand uh if you can
uh
at least write something or uh
participate in some grand uh preparation
i think that would be very helpful
yeah uh like i i did not have any grants
and i've never applied for a grant uh i
didn't get
any awards or anything like that when
you know i was a grad student or early
in my postdoc career um
but
you know what really you have to
basically show that you know
a the research you're doing is important
it's changing the direction of something
whatever field you're in uh and you can
not only that you can pump up pump out
that new research for the next however
many years
um
and you also have to establish your
independence from your advisor that that
was the one uh important advice that i
was given um so it's it's
you know as a postdoc
there's not a lot
again it depends upon your situation you
may have an opportunity to do it you may
not experimentless it's a little bit
hard because you know it's it's the lab
that your advisor has you basically do
what's in the lab pretty much for
theorists is a little bit uh easier you
can come up
you know all you need is a paper and pen
so you can do whatever the heck you want
to so in my case it was you know
i was able to demonstrate that my
research is
is different and different from my
advisor and that i'll be able to
continue that research uh
into the future
um so that's
that's i would say is important
and i
and i would also say that maybe applying
for a fellowship to be actually a put to
be a postdoctoral fellow
it's a process that would somehow also
teach us how to write a branch because
it's a short version of a grains that
you have to think about how that project
will be developed what are the what are
the scope objectives
then you go through a process of
selection
so this whole experience somehow it
starts to teach us how to write a grant
and if if we get that
that is something that is quite valuable
it's it's seen as a sign of independence
that you are able to
search for a
grant and eventually
get up get get approval
so
i would definitely advise like trying to
apply for a fellowship it's something
that would definitely advance
your
your abilities and will give you
much better chances to get hired
just one more thing that i forgot to say
earlier was also
try to get as many talk give as many
talks as possible including try to get
invited talks
uh they do look at that they want to
know that your
research is
important that people will actually you
know
request for you to come and talk about
your work and rather than you just you
know applying to talk somewhere
um and regarding fellowship there's more
and more big centers institute and
industry providing a positive girl
fellowship i know yqi has the the yql
fellowships um that actually are open
right now so you can apply you have
until november 15. just putting it out
there if you're interested
but there's also a ton of similar
programs everywhere um so these are like
we call them like gold star postdocs
it's similar to a regular puzzle but
they have a little bit of shine on it so
that might help you like it's not gonna
do everything but it might like shine a
little bit of varnish in your
application but that's also something
you can do that might help a little bit
um
and uh so yeah so looking at the last
few questions that i have um
regarding uh inviting uh talks like how
do you proceed for that like is it
similar to we have a question in the
chat about visiting scholars and
visiting researchers during phd and
doing post-docs is that something that
um you've done in the past or is it
something that we haven't seen uh even
done in
uh i personally haven't done any like
visiting uh followers or researchers and
any places so the reason is because i'm
an experimentalist so
it's basically i need to focus on one
experiment
uh
project and we have already built up the
capability in my own group so there's no
point for me to visit another group
and but i do see a lot of theories
visiting other institutes especially uh
many cases i find it fruitful to have a
theoretical researcher to visiting to
visit an experimental group and i in
many cases i find that discussion is
very helpful
thank you
um and then one i think one last thing
that i want to talk about uh that was
appointed by shruti i'm going to put
this slide up
there's the cm amo um rumor mill website
that
has a ton of uh information about all
the job posting um
did any of you used it for your
applications or like we're looking at
the different openings or is it
something that's uh just a good thing to
see the the shortlist
it's actually my first time just to know
this website
really
well for me like i was told that this is
where you basically live for the uh
you know during the application process
but no like i i did visit this website
quite frequently to look for um
you know new positions that are open and
which i might not have heard about
before
right so actually now when i
look for positions i do realize that
there's no centralized website or a
google place that can have all the
posted positions
so actually i'm a little bit curious
that you mentioned that you
said there's 161 positions last year i'm
wondering how to get that number
uh so i went through a stream the
actually this website they have a list
of everything and they uh so this one
the new posting for 2021 have only two
job posting right now but if you go in
the archive you have all the lists it's
an endless list of scroll through uh it
it doesn't mean that there was a 160
position uh it just means it just meant
that there was like some openings and i
don't know if the university actually
went through because of the pandemic and
the job shop edge uh like the freezing
of the
of the fundings but uh yeah that's
something that um
this is where i found all the
information and then it was also uh
chris uh chris posting like cross cross
referencing with uh all the job hosting
that we that are received because we
have uh we have an external announcement
section on our website and so this is i
i often get a ton of uh of job posting
from the other uh centers
also that's something like if you if you
look for uh for jobs that's something
that you can do uh looking at uh the
the your your university listing or your
department they might have a section uh
usually you're the chair of the
department or your pis received a ton a
ton of open position
you might be able to uh to ask them to
like hey if you see anything just
forward the email because they usually
don't have time to read it
but they if they know that you're
looking like if you if you tell them hey
i'm considering i think communication
with your advisor is really key and like
talk
i've seen people in conferences posting
at the end of the talk uh hey i'm
looking for position i'm looking for
jobs like it's really important to like
communicate what you want to do um
online presence is more and more
important uh so if you have a website if
you have a twitter like the quantum
tweeter is a very uh very active um it's
a it's a little bit sad to have
everybody on social media working on
like keep working uh outside of your
work on social media but uh it has been
uh pretty good resources to find a job
application for that if i can also add
something on this topic of job posting
and this has something to do with what
following what what what florian has
just mentioned
twitter it's a
great resource of information about job
postings
all the time
i saw like
advertisements about job postings on my
area i'm not in the right moment to
apply for for them yet
but if i if i if i wanted so
just last week i saw one amazing job
posting that was just passing
through my my
my my timeline
and
and also twitter is basically great for
networking as well i found my post
doctor position through twitter in a
very
in in a process of serendipity
by just clicking clicking and then
suddenly i found this
this job posting
one thing that i always recommend
uh
join twitter and try to use that
professionally
by having your bio describing who you
are where you went in in terms of your
background
and you start following people in your
field because eventually you may see on
their profile a job posting that you
would never find it by googling or by
looking at mailing lists because
on twitter you may by chance
uh find such information that are quite
useful and
such information comes from networking
in this online environment
thank you very much for that uh that
commander insight
we're almost out of time so what i
propose is uh we can go around and have
like maybe
the last advice of the of the hour uh
and then i'll i'll uh we can do around
and then i'll show you the uh the
upcoming events in this series
okay so like 30 seconds of wisdom from
uh all of you like what's the what's the
the best thing you can do or like maybe
just by squishies i guess
who wants to start uh sure do you want
to go
oh lord i didn't think about this before
um
no just i don't have much advice but i i
just want to say that um
you know when i was a postdoc i was very
unsure about
you know uh being an assistant you know
being a professor like i knew i wanted
to be that but i i wasn't very confident
or i wasn't sure whether i was going to
get
you know the position i wanted or not i
would just say don't be afraid you know
put yourself out there
if you're not going to take risks you're
not going to get a new award so just
just try it if that's something that you
want to do
don't worry about whether you think
you're good or bad or whatever just give
it a shot
um lane ryan do you want to do uh last
few words for me
um yeah i think uh as fruity mentioned
that there are a lot of consultancies
when finding a flexing position
my
advice is that
well uh
so we should still keep focus on your ex
research while you are searching for a
position so
of course
in the good situation you'll find a
position and you are ready to move to
start your new group but in a bad case
so you should continue your work and
prepare for the next round so my
suggestion is that
keep going continue with your current
research work and focus on that while
you are applying for fat situation
yeah thanks
thank you very much all uh for uh taking
the time to talk to us before we wrap up
the
the
these events i would like to point out a
few uh event that might be helpful
the c2qa which is the co-design center
for quantum advantage which is one of
the national hubs that the government's
put in place in the u.s this one is the
one that tia is part of out of
brookhaven national labs in long island
is hosting a quantum career fair
on september 22nd so if you're
interested go on their website and check
it out and then the next event for us so
we talked about a ton of uh different uh
way to get involved in uh in the quantum
fields as
either studying it in college doing a
phd in grad school we've talked about
how to put all the chances behind you to
become a faculty member we're gonna have
two more events in this series one in
october to prepare for startup the event
will be on october 27 at the same time
on friday at 4pm and then we'll have one
later on on industry jobs so if you uh
we should have in the span of the full
year covered uh all of the possibilities
uh that you can do and all the the
videos of these events are available uh
on youtube on our website so if you go
on quantum
institute.tl.edu videos you should be
able to see all of these all of these
events
thank you all uh for joining us uh i
really appreciate your time and insight
and i hope you
have a really
prosperity in your research groups and
amazon thank you so much for joining us
and giving us all this insight about the
ypa thank you all for attending and have
a good night